let's see if we can get a chuckle out of  this I said airports airports I can't  deal with the people that work at Hudson  booksellers what's wrong with those  people  what's up with the slowness of the  transaction I can't deal with the  slowness of the transaction when I want  to buy a book are those people what is  wrong with are they koala bears  okay I I you know I don't mean to keep  focusing on the audience but it's the  only interesting thing happening in this  clip  and there's one guy I don't know if you  heard the one guy in particular in the  audience and he just lost it on the  koala bear joke koala bears  which didn't make sense anyway by the  way because actually koala bears can run  up to 30 miles per hour and I did look  that up so they're not known for being  slow necessarily but also what's the it  just she says koala bear koala bear  koala bear  koala bear that's rich that's just lazy  writing